Candy truth.
>> Whoa.
>> So, we're out here in Nashville,
Tennessee at the Parthonon.
When this world was still young,
long before man or beast roamed these
lands,
>> I created them.
>> The goddess Athena. This thing is like
40 foot tall, $30,000 of gold or
something like that. And that's right
here in Nashville.
Now, there's a prophecy written by Ellen
White where she had a vision.
>> While I was in Nashville, a scene was
opened up before me. It was the night
before the Sabbath. That is when that
scene was presented. I looked out of the
window and there was an immense ball of
fire that had come from heaven. and it
fell where they were casting buildings
with pillars, especially the pillars
were presented to me. And it seemed as
if the ball came right to the building
and crushed it. And they saw that it was
branching out, enlarging, and they began
to cry and mourn and mourn and ring
their hands. And I thought some of our
people stood by there saying, "Well, it
is just what we have been expecting. It
is just what we have been talking about.
It is just what we have been talking
about. You knew it, said some of the
people. You knew it and never told us
about it.
>> And that was just like part of what's
going to come in the last days that many
cities are going to be destroyed by fire
from heaven.
>> Just behind me here in Atlanta, a
fireball lit up the skyline. Not just in
Georgia, but also nearby states such as
South Carolina, North Carolina, and even
Tennessee. People in South Carolina,
Tennessee, and Georgia were startled
Thursday when they saw what looked like
a fireball streak across the sky before
creating a sonic boom. And so, you know,
it's an interesting thing to see this in
real life and know that that that
prophecy didn't come out until like 10
years ago, but it it recently came out.
It wasn't really in the great
controversy. Like, it mentioned it was a
city, but didn't mention the city by
name. And then later the Ellen White
estate
uh released what the city that was. And
so it's kind of a big deal to talk about
this. I don't think a lot of people want
to cuz it sounds crazy, but can you
blame God?
[Music]
Every tile has a symbol of the sun.
I mean, look. This is huge. This is a
false idol right here. 40 foot tall.
>> And she's holding the goddess Nike in
her hand right there.
>> As well as serpents,
>> the huge serpent right there.
>> And on her belt is serpents. And on her
>> on her arms, each bracelet is a serpent
as well. We have noticed on Athena's
shield here, there is a face as well.
It's one that is implanted into her
chest, I believe, also. But if you'll
see this guy right there,
um, we notice the tongue. The tongue is
sticking out. And if you guys have ever
seen what's with the tongue, uh, that
little light put out, I made that.
And there's a verse here that
accompanies it. It says, "Against whom
do you sport yourselves? Against whom
make you a wide mouth and draw out the
tongue? Are you not children of
transgression, a seed of falsehood?"
Isaiah 57:4.
Yeah, there's a lot of gods. She's not
the only one here.
>> Oh, yeah. They're all over on the
outside. There's Hermes and Zeus and all
those guys.
So, here is the Greek Parthonon with the
goddess Athena in there. And look, right
across the way
is the coliseum where you can play
football or whatever sport in honor of
the god right here, the goddess. So,
here's the parthonon right here. And as
you can see, the First Bank Stadium is
right here across the way, directly in
front of it. And we did an episode on
the Olympics and how if you go to
Olympics.com, they will tell you that
the Olympics were formed in honor of
Zeus. They it was a religious ritual to
Zeus. And then I started looking around
even more. Why would fireballs come down
and hit this area? Well, here's this
stadium that we know they're games to
Zeus. Here's the Parthonon with Athena
in there. Here's the Parthonon towers.
Directly behind the Parthonon, Taylor
Swift bench. She is a witch. She's the
richest woman in the music industry.
She's definitely wicked. Rothschild
College. Rothschild. If you haven't
looked into this stuff, look into the
Rothschild, the Bilderbergs. I'm trying
to find some everywhere. I kept seeing
these fraternal organizations. Let me
see if I can find some. Kappa alpha
order kappa delta alpha epsilon pi beta
delta pi fi delta theta. I mean they are
everywhere. NPHC fraternities and saying
I'm not shocked at all that uh this
place is going to get hit by fireballs
when right here in this one screenshot
you see Taylor Swift Parthonon Coliseum
Rothschild College. This is pretty
mind-blowing guys.
>> So if if God was going to bring
destruction anywhere I'm not surprised
that it would be here honestly. Candid
truth.
[Music]